[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24 y
nos acompaña en el estudio más Romero
salamar nos vamos ahogando donde se
crear un brote de ébola hace ya una
semana Cómo está la situación
actualmente Así es Raúl muy buenos días
es una noticia que como tal llegó el
martes pasado pero aprovechamos ahora
que cumple esta semana para repasar Cómo
está la situación fue la primera
declaración de una muerte por ébola en
uganda desde 2019 y Este era el anuncio
que hacían desde el Ministerio de salud
el 15 de septiembre hubo un caso
sospechoso de un hombre de 24 años que
se reportó en el hospital de muvende se
aisló la muestra se tomó el 18 de
septiembre los resultados llegaron ayer
por la noche para confirmar que se
trataba de ébola de la cepa de Sudán
una semana después entonces de este
anuncio la última actualización del
Ministerio de salud que tiene fecha del
25 de septiembre y hace dos días es de
36 casos acumulados 23 muertes
acumuladas vemos que es la mitad por lo
tanto por ahora una mortalidad de
aproximadamente el 50% aunque esto no se
va a saber del cierto hasta que termine
el brote y vemos que hay también algunas
muertes o algunos casos confirmados y
otros probables queríamos aprovechar
para recordar que cuando se declaran
estos casos probables no es que pueda
ser que sí existe la sospecha que sí
sino que realmente hay muchas
indicaciones epidemiológicas de que son
casos y pues a muertes por ébola pero
que no se han podido confirmar no por
ejemplo este chico que nombraba ministra
bueno la secretaria del Ministerio de
salud que llegó con contagios luego se
fue a su comunidad y se vio que allí
habían fallecido Ya seis personas más
pero ya estaban enterradas entonces
falta esa confirmación clínica de
laboratorio que todavía no se tiene pero
digamos que con bastante seguridad se
puede hablar por ejemplo de estas 23
muertes ahora qué es esta cepa de Sudán
márque nombraba el Ministerio de salud
del ébola lo provoca un virus recordemos
y ahí estas seis cepas tres de las
cuales causan enfermedades la de
bundibujillo Sudán y zaire zaire es la
que ha protagonizado digamos los últimos
brotes en la última década más o menos y
en cambio la de Sudán suele ser algo más
rara está asociada con menos mortalidad
la variante del zaire tiene
aproximadamente un 70% de mortalidad en
cambio la de Sudán alrededor del 40% son
cifras de elevadísimas que además
todavía pueden ser incluso más altas y
no hay una respuesta rápida de los
gobiernos y de la sociedad hay una
justicia y es que la vacuna que se usa
contra el ébola está demostrada su
eficacia contradecíamos la cepa del
zaire pero no contra la cepa de Sudán
precisamente porque se desarrolló en los
últimos años y no han habido brotes de
la cepazo tan en los últimos años que se
haya podido comprobar si la vacuna
realmente eficaz o no en estos En estos
casos imaginamos que ahora en cambio
tendremos pues más datos Y más cifras al
respecto de esto esta esta variante esta
cepa Perdona del Sudán se ha dado en
cuatro ocasiones en uganda tres en Sudán
aprovechar también para recordar que la
OMS pues recomienda no ponerle nombres
de lugares geográficos ni a las
enfermedades ni a las variantes en este
caso se siguen llamando así y la otra
vez que apareció fue hace 10 años en
2012 con un brote relativamente pequeño
mucho más pequeño que el que ya se está
registrando ahora por ejemplo pero en el
año 2000 sí causó 200 muertes digamos
Market podríamos rescatar alguna buena
noticia alrededor de este brote pues en
verdad así aunque sea relativamente no
más allá de la experiencia acumulada que
ya tiene uganda y muchos países de la
región africana en luchar contra el
ébola en combatir estos brotes también
sabemos que la pandemia de Kobe 19 pues
ha dado muchas más herramientas mucho
más experiencia y también
infraestructura para luchar contra el
brote actual de precisamente así lo
destacaban también recientemente desde
el Ministerio de salud
esta emergencia se produce justo al fin
de la pandemia de Kobe 19 que creemos
haber manejado con éxito y gran parte de
la infraestructura que hemos usado para
el Kobe 19 será rápidamente reutilizada
para el ébola
We have significante tenemos una
capacidad considerable gracias a
nuestros puestos en territorio de
detectar y despertar una respuesta
rápida de la comunidad
para decir que haces casas dos horas
llegó una noticia de que República
democrática del Congo había declarado el
fin a un mini brote de un caso que se
había de en agosto y después de 45 días
desde que se detectó eso caso Perdón 42
días unos ha registrado ningún contagio
nuevo entonces también han declarado el
fin a este pequeño brote por lo tanto
bueno tenemos estas buenas noticias así
sean relativamente
porque sigue reapareciendo el ébola
claro esa es una gran pregunta no porque
sabemos todos recordamos de ese gran
brote que sucedió entre 2014 y 2016 de
la angustia los titulares que ocupó pero
desde entonces se ha ido volviendo a
detectar Aunque De hecho no ha parado
detectarse desde 1976 que es cuando se
descubrió el virus del ébola recordamos
aquí tenemos un histórico digamos de la
última década más o menos
2014-2016 ese gran caso con más de
28.000 casos más de 11.000 de personas
que murieron sobre todo en tres países
Sierra de leona Guinea y Liberia que
fueron los que más sufrieron Este embate
pero desde entonces vemos que van
apareciendo casi cada año nuevos brotes
uno de los más grandes también en 2018
que se extendió tanto República
democrática del Congo como en uganda de
hecho duró hasta 2019 fue algo un brote
que duró también algo más de un año y
seguimos viendo como República
democrática del Congo es la gran
protagonista no Sigue apareciendo en
todos estos brotes que se van
registrando porque es uno de los países
donde es endémico Y es que hay un
problema y es que este virus del ébola
se encuentra en reservorios de animales
todavía no se sabe con total certeza
Cuáles pero se cree que son unos
murciélagos y mientras este virus sigue
existiendo en estos animales y los
humanos sigan teniendo contacto tanto
con estos murciélagos como con otros
animales que se pueden infectar pues es
muy difícil contener esta enfermedad va
a seguir apareciendo van a ver si pues
van a seguir apareciendo estos brotes
esto es se llama en inglés pero es que
además también se supo recientemente
pues recientemente en los últimos dos
años digamos que es que este virus se
puede quedar como en un estado de
letargo como en una especie de infección
permanente en algunos lugares del cuerpo
de las personas y Eso provoca que pueda
volver a aparecer Incluso en una persona
que se había contagiado que había
sobrevivido a la ébola hacía un año o
algo más y también provocar así se cree
que algunos de estos brotes de los que
estábamos hablando pues fueron
precisamente por esto por alguien que se
había contagiado que su sobrevivió a un
brote anterior y que volvió a despertar
una cadena de contagio una cadena de
transmisión después al cabo de como año
año y medio aproximadamente mar como
siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información de salud por supuesto mañana